depuis le 27 juin notre pays a connu des
nuits de troubles et d'affrontement des
nuits durant lesquelles nous avons été
nombreux sur les bancs de cette
hémicycle a appelé au calme appelé au
respect de la loi de la République
durant ces nuits les policiers les
gendarmes et les sapeurs-pompiers
l'ensemble des services de l'État se
sont mobilisés et ont répondu avec le
plus grand professionnalisme un
dévouement exemplaire à des situations
tendues et violentes pourtant au sein de
notre hémicycle certains députés font
peu de cas du travail immense pour
ramener le calme dans nos rues ces élus
soufflent les braises en participant à
des manifestations interdites par les
services de l'État en écharpe tricolore
quand certains chantent tout le monde
détestent la police je crois que les
Français dans leur ensemble ont été
extrêmement choqués que des
parlementaires en écharpe puissent
défiler au son de tout le monde déteste
la police
et je veux dire que ceux qui ont défilé
au son de tout le monde déteste la
police sans s'écarter
sans faire un tweet sans regretter ne
déshonore pas la police nationale mais
déshonore leurs mandat et la vie de
femme et d'hommes politiques
alors madame la députée plutôt que
donner publicité à des extrémistes qui
crachent sur la tombe des policiers
morts je voudrais ici depuis 3 ans
vous lire et j'espère vous faire
applaudir dans l'ensemble de cette
émission tous les policiers morts en
service et qui laissent des veufs des
meufs des orphelins
Frank Laboa
Éric Mauroy
Freddy Allard
romain boulange
Vincent Martinez
Stéphane le beurre
Amaury la Groix de croûte
Stéphanie montfermé
Eric Masson
Wilfried Faron
Steven keblack
Manon
Paul Medeiros
vive la république et vive la police
nationale
[Applaudissements]